.
Der Nebel kommt. Es sieht so aus,
als ob wir uns beeilen müssten.
Es ist nicht so schlimm.
5.30 Uhr auf der Basis
der Air Zermatt.
Pilot Gerold Biner checkt das Wetter.
Drei Frauen sind blockiert in einer
Wand und warten auf ihre Rettung.
Die haben
wohl nicht so gut geschlafen.
Räuspern
Sie werden jetzt befreit.
In einer Stunde trinken sie Kaffee.
Helikopterlärm, spannende Musik
Sie sind die Retter in der Not.
Sie fliegen in der Bergwelt
rund ums Matterhorn.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Wir begleiten Gerold Biner,
Robi Andenmatten,
Markus Koch
und Patrese.
Reale Geschichten
aus der Welt der Rettungsteams.
Der Sommeralltag der Air Zermatt.
Der Rettungsheli mit Gerold
und Rettungssanitäter Furri
befindet sich
im Anflug auf die Hörnlihütte.
Ihr Einsatz: Evakuierung
von drei Frauen am Obergabelhorn.
Tipptopp.
Es ist gut.
Bei der Hörnlihütte steigt
Kurt Lauber zu, der Hüttenwart.
Er ist Rettungsspezialist
und soll die Bergsteigerinnen aus
ihrer misslichen Situation erlösen.
Ciao, Kurt!
Geht es dir gut?
- Tipptopp. Euch auch?
Ja. Du siehst gut aus!
Lachen
Helikopterlärm, spannende Musik
Die Frauen sind
vom vielen Schnee überrascht worden
und mussten eine Nacht lang in
einer kalten, steilen Wand ausharren,
nachdem gestern
ein erster Rettungsversuch
infolge des schlechten Wetters
scheiterte.
Ich mache eine Drehung.
Gemeinsam suchen die drei Bergretter
die Wand am Obergabelhorn
nach den Bergsteigerinnen ab.
Man kann Spuren erkennen.
Da sieht man sie.
Gerold, bleib so!
Und tatsächlich, da sind sie,
auf einem winzigen Felsvorsprung
haben sie übernachtet.
Guten Morgen!
Habt ihr gut geschlafen?
Sie haben
ein super Hotel ausgesucht.
Diese Nische ist super.
... Mittelgabelhorn.
Inzwischen trifft Patrese
auf der Basis ein.
Gemeinsam mit Mechaniker Hanspeter
Wyer ist er einer der ersten.
Riffelberg?
- Ja.
Mit Gerold?-- Ja.
- Dann hat er "Papa Juliette".
Sie rüsten den Heli,
der nachts unterwegs war,
für Einsätze am Tag um.
Das ist ein Nachtscheinwerfer.
Gibt es nachts eine Suchaktion,
kann man damit
die Gegend beleuchten.
Auf dem Gletscher
hat sich Kurt Lauber
unter dem Heli am Seil eingehängt.
Gerold hebt den Heli langsam an.
Kurt gibt ihm
die Höhe per Funk durch.
Funk:Einen halben Meter.
Ab Boden.
Spannende Musik
Kurt, wie geht's?
Tipptopp.
30 m unter dem Helikopter,
an einem Seil hängend,
schwebt der Rettungsspezialist
durch die Luft.
Bin ich zu schnell?
- Nein, es ist gut, Gerold.
Pilot Gerold erkundigt sich
immer wieder nach seinem Befinden.
Gerold, ich hänge mich zuerst ein.
Jawohl.
Kurz vor der Wand übernimmt Kurt
unten am Seil das Kommando.
Er weist Gerold präzise ein.
Die Anweisungen sind wegen
des Helilärms nicht zu verstehen.
Dann löst er sich vom Seil.
Es reicht nicht für alle,
zwei und zwei.
Sie beschliessen, jeweils
zwei Personen aufs Mal auszufliegen.
Kurt fixiert Karabiner
am Klettergurt der Bergsteigerinnen.
Es ist gut, Gerold.
Auf den Meter genau muss Gerold
das Seil in Kurts Hände fliegen.
Dann hängt er die zwei Frauen
am Klettergurt ein.
Die ersten beiden Kletterinnen
werden zu einem Zwischenlandeplatz
geflogen.
Auf der Basis steht heute
der 200-Std.-Service
beim Helikopter "November Delta" an.
Auch Pilot Markus ist da.
Hast du die Dämpfer
bei "Papa Juliette" entlüftet"?
Nein.
Wenn du Zeit hast,
wäre das nicht schlecht.
Wir landeten auf unebenem Boden,
danach gab es Vibrationen.
Es eilt nicht so sehr.
Gerold hat die beiden Frauen
abgesetzt
und holt nun Kurt und
die dritte Kletterin aus der Wand.
Spannende Musik
Am sicheren Seil entschweben
Kurt Lauber und die Bergsteigerin
der kalten Wand.
Spannende Musik
Inzwischen sitzt Patrese
in der Gornergratbahn.
Durchsage:
Nächster Halt: Riffelalp.
Riffelalp.
Ich bin lange nicht mehr
mit der Bahn gefahren.
Ich noch nie.
Auf dem Riffelboden
steigt er aus.
Auf ihn wartet ein harter Tag.
Betonieren ist angesagt.
Patrese füllt Kessel um Kessel
mit Beton.
Der Heli bringt sie zur Baustelle,
wo die neue Luftseilbahn
Riffelberg-Express entsteht.
Im Cockpit sitzt Robi.
Funk:
Da ist das Limit, mehr geht nicht.
Sanfte Musik
Flüge und Transporte auf Baustellen
sind für die Air Zermatt
eine wichtige Einnahmequelle.
Von Rettungen und Rundflügen alleine
könnte das Heli-Unternehmen
nicht existieren.
Robi fliegt bis zu 30 Rotationen
pro Stunde.
Auf der Basis treffen
die geretteten Bergsteigerinnen ein.
Zeit für einen Kaffee?
Eine kalte Nacht in der Wand,
die Ungewissheit,
und nun die Rettung.
Wäre es auch ohne gegangen?
Möchten Sie Tee oder Kaffee?
Haben Sie sich
Räubergeschichten erzählt?
Geschwatzt haben wir nicht viel.
Im Biwak ging es gut?
- Ja.
Möchten Sie schwarzen Tee?
Zurückgehen
wäre auch schwierig gewesen.
Das hätten wir vielleicht
machen können.
Aber bei der Wärme hätte es
Steinschlag geben können.
Ja, es war sicher besser so.
Wir haben es uns schon überlegt.
Betonieren ist Massarbeit
und benötigt Fingerspitzengefühl.
Es ist ein enges Zusammenspiel
zwischen Robi und Patrese.
Bis auf 30 kg genau
muss Patrese die Kessel füllen.
Das sind etwa 598 kg.
600 kg sollten es sein.
Die Funksprüche
sind nicht zu verstehen.
Das ist leider alles,
was wir hier haben.
Wenn wir gewusst hätten,
dass ihr allein dort oben seid,
wären wir gestern schon gekommen.
Gelächter
Es hatte so viel Schnee,
wir sind fast ertrunken darin.
Wo es weniger Schnee hatte,
waren die Felsen rutschig.
Wir entschieden,
kein Risiko einzugehen.
Es kommen weitere
gerettete Bergsteiger an.
Zwei Ungaren mussten
am Dom evakuiert werden.
Yesterday, it was really ...
heavy snow ...
Dicker Nebel und viel Schnee.
Wir konnten die Route nicht finden.
Entschuldigung, bitte.
Die Rettung kostet über 1'000 Fr.
Carmen Lauber kontrolliert,
ob die beiden versichert sind.
Das ist deine Versicherungskarte.
Hast du auch eine?
Ich habe eine andere.
Sie wissen nicht,
ob Sie versichert sind?
Nein.- Sie besitzen also keine.
- Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Und tatsächlich -
nur einer ist versichert.
Das ist die Rechnung für beide,
aber nur eine Rettung ist gedeckt.
Ich werde nun
die Karte überprüfen.
You can drink your coffee
and we will check
if your card will pay that.
Robi ist bereits
für einen weiteren Auftrag unterwegs.
Eine Kuh liegt tot auf einer Alp
und muss geborgen werden.
Im Talboden
steigt Bauer Anton Schaller ein.
Er lotst sie zum toten Tier.
Da, geradeaus.
Weiter, noch weiter.
Gerade sechs Jahre alt
ist Kuh Jescha geworden.
Auf der Basis versucht Carmen Lauber,
bei den Ungaren das Geld
für die Rettung einzutreiben.
Haben Sie eine Kreditkarte?
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich eine habe.
Mal sehen.
Ich habe leider nur den Fahrausweis
und etwas Bargeld, aber nicht viel.
Ihr seid also hier in den Ferien
und habt kein Geld?
Wir kommen normalerweise
nicht in eine solche Situation.
Das ist das erste Mal
in zehn Jahren.
Und wie geht es nun weiter?
Ihr müsst die Rechnung
hier bezahlen
und bekommt sie dann von
der Versicherung zurückerstattet.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Sie sprechen ungarisch.
Könnten wir mit unseren Freunden
aus der Schweiz telefonieren?
Vielleicht können sie uns helfen.
Klar. Habt ihr ein Telefon?
Im Talboden steigt Bauer Schaller
wieder aus dem Helikopter.
Robi fliegt zurück auf die Alp,
um die tote Kuh zu bergen.
Sie war schon länger krank.
Sie hatte Probleme
mit der Gebärmutter.
Wir versuchten alles Mögliche.
Plötzlich sah man,
dass es nicht mehr ging.
Die Tierärztin kam und sagte,
die Kuh sei innerlich vergiftet.
Eine Rettung sei unmöglich.
Aus diesem Grund
haben wir uns entschlossen,
die Kuh zu töten
und abzutransportieren.
Auf der Basis haben die Ungaren
ihre Schweizer Freunde erreicht.
Guten Tag, Frau Frauenfelder.
Wir haben sie am Dom evakuiert.
Sie hatten schon gestern
und vorgestern Probleme.
Das Problem ist,
dass sie keine Versicherung haben,
zumindest einer nicht.
Eine Person
hat gar keine Versicherung.
Die Rettung kostet 1'794.40 Fr.,
für beide.
Mussten wir Sie
auch schon evakuieren?
Wann war das?
Anscheinend sind
die Schweizer Freunde
tatsächlich vor ein paar Tagen
auch schon evakuiert worden.
Sie wurden auch schon evakuiert.
Sie lacht.
Und Sie würden
diese Rechnung übernehmen?
Einer ist versichert. Ihm wird
der Betrag zurückerstattet.
Der andere hat kaum etwas.
Sechs Jahre lang war die Kuh Jescha
jeden Sommer auf seiner Alp.
Eine gute Milchkuh, wie er sagt.
Melancholische Musik
Danke. Ade, danke.
Diese Kollegen
haben wir am Sonntag evakuiert.
Diese zwei Schweizer haben
die Ungaren zufällig getroffen.
Sie sind bereit, die Rechnung
der Ungaren zu übernehmen.
Das gibt es sehr selten,
eigentlich nie.
Ihr habt gute Freunde!
Wir wissen das.
Sie haben uns garantiert,
dass sie eure Rechnung bezahlen.
Ihr müsst ihnen
das Geld direkt zurückzahlen.
Robi befindet sich im Anflug auf
die Basis am Dorfeingang von Zermatt.
Rund 25-30 Mitarbeitende sind während
der Hochsaison hier beschäftigt.
Auf der Basis wird er von Sohn Timmy
empfangen, der Ferien hat.
Was hast du gemacht?
Ich war auf der Hütte
und dann kam ich hierher.
Kevin war nicht da. Aber morgen
gehen wir mit ihm klettern.
Die Hörnlihütte am Matterhorn.
Hüttenwart und Rettungsspezialist
Kurt Lauber
ist nach der Evakuation der Frauen
wieder zurückgekehrt.
Besorgt beobachtet er das Matterhorn.
Das Wetter ist schön.
Touristen und Bergsteiger
sind unterwegs,
aber die Verhältnisse sind prekär.
Am Einstieg zum Matternhorn
trifft Kurt Lauber auf Rumänen.
Wie sind die Verhältnisse?
Verhältnisse?
Ich glaube, sie sind gut.
Sie sind gut?
Ja. Ich glaube,
besser als vor vier Jahren.
Aber es hat viel Schnee.
Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Sie reden englisch.
Es klettern nicht viele Leute.
Das ist doch gut.
Die Verhältnisse sind schlecht.
Warum denn?
- Weil Schnee in der Wand liegt.
Warst du schon oben?
Ich war schon 320-mal oben.
Aber jetzt würde ich nicht gehen.
Das ist eben speziell
bei osteuropäischen Expeditionen.
Das wissen wir.
Wir haben wenig Möglichkeiten.
Wenn wir da sind, klettern wir.
Wir kalkulieren das Risiko.
Denkt ihr auch an die Bergretter?
- Ich bin auch einer.
Dann solltest du wissen,
was das bedeutet.
Dein Rat ist,
morgen nicht zu klettern?
Ich würde das nie sagen.
Jeder ist alt genug.
Aber derzeit kann man das Matter-
horn nicht in einem Tag erklimmen.
Und bald kommt wieder
schlechtes Wetter.
Dann haben wir Bergretter
wieder ein Problem.
Er spricht englisch.
Na dann viel Glück!
Funk:
Es geht Richtung Weissmies.
Zwei Patienten sind bewusstlos.
Funk:
Okay.
Die schlechten Verhältnisse
fordern erste Opfer.
Auf der Basis startet die "Ecofox",
ein Heli, der wie eine fliegende
Intensivstation eingerichtet ist.
Funk:Es sind zwei Bewusstlose.
Wir übernehmen je einen.
Ein weiterer Helikopter
ist im Anflug auf die Hörnlihütte,
wo Kurt Lauber abgeholt wird.
Einsatz: Spaltensturz am Weissmies.
Funk:
Verstanden.
Funk:Zur Information:
Zwei Patienten sind bewusstlos.
Insgesamt sind fünf Bergsteiger
am Weissmies
in eine Gletscherspalte gestürzt.
Das ist der Weissmies.
Pilot Benno und Kurt Lauber
besprechen die Lage.
Es soll einige Leute haben.
Da sind schon einige.
Kannst du noch eine Runde drehen,
damit ich die Situation sehen kann?
Mehrere Bergsteigergruppen
stehen um die Spalte,
in welche die Seilschaft stürzte
und wagen sich nicht mehr weiter.
Ohne Steigeisen ist das blöd.
Nach der Landung
kannst du sofort nachschauen.
Pilot Benno landet unten
bei der Weissmieshütte.
Er setzt Kurt Lauber ab, während er
weitere Rettungsspezialisten holt.
Auch die "Ecofox"
mit dem Arzt landet.
Während Kurt
als erster zur Spalte fliegt,
macht sich hier das Team
von Rettungssanität und Arzt bereit,
um allfällige Verletzte
zu versorgen.
Schauen wir mal ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob es Sinn macht,
oben bei den Spalten
zwei Patienten zu versorgen.
Wenn's steil ist ...
Wenn man intubieren muss,
ist es hier unten besser.
Zuerst war nur die Rede
von einem Leichtverletzten.
Es ist aber offenbar schlimmer.
Wir holen sie runter
und versorgen sie hier weiter.
Pilot Benno
hat Kurt bei der Spalte abgesetzt.
Dieser funkt von der Unfallstelle.
Funk:Fünf Personen
sind in der Spalte,
zwei bewusstlos
und schwer verletzt.
Fünf in einer Spalte, zwei davon
bewusstlos und schwer verletzt.
So die erste Information von Kurt.
Nun geht es darum,
die Verletzten zu bergen.
Arzt Tim wird am Seil
sofort auf den Gletscher geflogen.
Patrese ist in Zermatt
heute als Ambulanzfahrer im Einsatz.
Es gibt eine Patientenverlegung:
vom Heli zum Arzt.
Ein Junge stürzte beim Snowboarden
und muss zum Arzt
ins Dorf gebracht werden.
Sie reden durcheinander.
Mit dem Sack?
- Ja.
1, 2, 3.
Die Situation am Weissmies
spitzt sich immer weiter zu.
Ein dritter Heli der Air Zermatt
mit Arzt Axel kommt zu Hilfe.
Fünf drin?
Drei sind wahrscheinlich
unverletzt.
Was hat derjenige, der verletzt ist?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Die Rede war
von zwei Bewusstlosen.
Wer ist jetzt oben?
Unser Arzt ...
- Tim.- Ja.
Er soll in der Spalte
keine grosse Versorgung machen,
sondern hierher fliegen.
Wir warten ab und schauen,
was sie sagen.
Kurt Lauber fliegt mit einem weiteren
Rettungsspezialisten zurück.
Ihre Arbeit an der Unfallstelle
ist getan.
Kurt war in der Spalte und
hat die Bergsteiger herausgeholt.
Nicht alle haben überlebt.
Die Situation war so,
dass eine Fünferseilschaft
im Abstieg vom Weissmies war.
Ein Mitglied dieser Seilschaft
ist in einem Steilhang
in eine Spalte gestürzt
und hat natürlich
die andern vier mitgerissen.
Sie sind etwa 15 m tief
in die Spalte gefallen.
Drei davon sind leicht verletzt.
Zwei haben leider
ihr Leben verloren.
Wahrscheinlich durch den Sturz
oder weil sie eine Weile
unter dem Schnee lagen.
Im Nachhinein ist schwierig zu
sagen, was die Todesursache ist.
Ich habe noch nicht oft erlebt,
dass gleich fünf Personen
in eine Spalte stürzten.
Aber eben. Es gibt nichts,
was es nicht gibt.
Funk:
Ja, verstanden.
Funk:Wenn ihr den Patienten
abgeliefert habt,
könnt ihr weiter zu Dr. Bannwart.
Dort wartet eine Patientin, 35,
mit einer Augenverletzung.
Sie kommt zum Heliport.
Patrese ist mit seinem Patienten
unterwegs.
Funk:Verstanden.
Dr. Bannwart, Heliport.
Langsam schnell fahren!
Langsam schnell fahren
in den Strassen von Zermatt,
die eigentlich autofrei sind.
Die Trage können wir gleich für
den nächsten Patienten brauchen.
Geräusch vom Öffnen
der Klettverschlüsse.
Er hatte ziemlich starke Schmerzen.
Passiert ist es beim Snowboarden.
Ade.
Die Bergretter fliegen die ersten
Überlebenden des Spaltensturzes
zur Weissmieshütte,
wo sie von den Rettungssanitätern
und Arzt Axel betreut werden.
Der Helikopter hebt wieder ab,
um die Toten zu bergen.
Eine Seilschaft
ist komplett in die Spalte gefallen.
Der erste ausgerutscht?
- Ja, und er hat alle mitgerissen.
Ausgerutscht?
- Ja, ja.
I think. Nicola just slipped down.
Dann konnten wir uns
nicht mehr halten.
Auch der dritte Bergsteiger
wird in Sicherheit gebracht.
Dann seid ihr alle fünf ...
Ja, alle fünf fielen in die Spalte.
Dann kam noch Schnee herunter.
Zwei wurden damit bedeckt.
Konntet ihr sie nicht
gleich rausziehen?
Nein, das dauerte.
- Wieso?
Es sind auch ganze Eisbrocken
heruntergefallen.
Zuerst mussten wir uns befreien,
damit wir wieder beweglich waren.
Beim einen lagen die Beine draussen,
aber der Kopf nicht.
Er hatte noch den Rucksack
auf dem Kopf.
Ist das eine Verletzung?
- Nein, es ist nur eine Schürfwunde.
Zieh mal hoch! Gut.
Sei froh, dass ihr unverletzt seid.
Du musst das quasi
als Geburtstag sehen.
Ja.
Geht's mit dem Rücken?
- Okay.
Der Bergsteiger hat sich
beim Spaltensturz am Auge verletzt.
Sie sind zusammen gekommen?
Schliessen Sie bitte beide Augen!
Okay.
Ich weiss nicht,
wo die andere Seilschaft ist.
Hast du geführt?
Nein,
geführt hat einer der beiden,
die jetzt noch da unten liegen
oder rausgeholt werden.
Du weisst, dass beide tot sind.
- Ja.
Wer ist der andere?
Ein Italiener, Nicola.
Die Verletzten werden nun mit dem
Heli ins Spital nach Visp geflogen.
Wir haben drei Patienten,
die nach Visp gebracht werden.
Wir werden dich jetzt abholen.
Funk:Okay.
Ich kann hier nichts mehr tun.
Stimmengewirr, sanfte Musik
Wenn wir in der Luft sind,
heizen wir.
Im Spital wird man Ihnen
eine warme Decke geben.
Wir starten in rund 5 Min.
Der Helikopter wird gestartet.
Auch für Kurt Lauber und Pilot Benno
ist die Aktion abgeschlossen.
Sie verabschieden sich via Funk:
Danke, Kurt. Es war super.
Der Rettungsspezialist
lässt sich Zeit beim Aussteigen.
Es gab einen Spaltensturz
mit mehreren Personen.
Da war gerade ziemlich viel los.
Okay.
In dem Fall ...
Das wünsche ich dir auch.
Merci.
Ja, dir auch. Tschüss!
Kurt Lauber
muss bereits wieder weiter,
zurück in die Hörnlihütte,
wo viel Arbeit auf ihn wartet.
Das Schicksal der Seilschaft
beschäftigt Gerold.
Er spricht mit Axel und Tim,
die am Einsatz dabei waren.
Ich habe nicht alles
vom Unglück mitbekommen.
Axel, du warst dabei
beim Spalteneinsatz?
Es beschäftigt dich schon.
Wenn man nicht direkt involviert
ist, ist es anders.
Man baut
einen Schutzmechanismus auf.
Mit der Zeit
ist es wie ein Automatismus.
Wenn man selber dabei ist ...
Es braucht schon
gewisse Voraussetzungen,
sonst kann man
den Job nicht machen.
Das merkt man aber sehr schnell.
Heute freute man sich zuerst
mit jenen, die überlebten.
Dann realisieren sie, was passiert
ist und sind untröstlich.
Meine Einstellung dazu ist,
dass jeder freiwillig
auf den Berg steigt.
Es weiss jeder,
dass es gefährlich ist.
Situationen wie heute sind heftig,
aber so ist es halt.
Na ja ...
Man kann sich nie daran gewöhnen.
Es ist schon etwas ...
Pilot Markus ist mit 650 kg Material
für die Hörnlihütte unterwegs,
u.a. Kartoffeln und Käse
für die Hüttenrösti und Getränke.
Wir sehen die Hütte.
Sie liegt leicht im Nebel.
Wir kommen problemlos hin.
Kurt Lauber erwartet ihn.
Funk:Markus, es ist nur
eine dünne Nebelschwade.
Die Südseite ist offen.
Kein Problem, Kurt.
Das geht gut, danke.
Regelmässig versorgen
die Piloten der Air Zermatt
die Hütten im ganzen Oberwallis.
Kurt, ich lasse den Haken runter.
Okay, tipptopp.
Zusätzlich hat Markus
noch ein besonderes Geschenk
aus seinem Heimatkanton mitgebracht:
echten Entlebucher Bäzi
für die Mitarbeiter der Hörnlihütte.
Der Flug war für ihn
auch nicht ganz uneigennützig,
denn seine Freundin Else
arbeitet diesen Sommer auf der Hütte.
Er hat sie lange nicht gesehen.
Hoi!
Wie geht's?
- Tipptopp.
Gut. Nerven sie dich nicht zu sehr?
- Nein.
Ihr geht später.
Und schon heisst es wieder
Abschied nehmen.
Uups ...
- Halte dich fest!
Also, ciao Schneckchen.
Kommst du mit nach oben?
Nein, ich verabschiede mich hier.
- Ciao, tschüss.
Bis später!
Bis bald!
Ciao.
- Ciao.
Auf dem Rückflug ins Tal trans-
portiert er den Abfall der Hütte.
Dort sind noch zwei.
Auf der Terrasse der Hörnlihütte
sitzen die Touristen
und beobachten das Matterhorn.
Kurt und Else schauen nach dem Zelt
der rumänischen Bergsteiger.
Von hier aus
sieht die Hütte anders aus.
Trotz der Warnung von Kurt
sind sie gestern aufgebrochen
und immer noch nicht zurück.
Das müsste das Zelt
der drei Rumänen sein.
Ja.
- Sie sind immer noch nicht zurück.
Die sind noch dort oben.
- Ja, die sind noch dort oben.
Die werden schon kommen.
Vielleicht kommen sie bald.
Mal schauen ...
Hier hat es viel Material,
das schon lange hier liegt.
Im Tal startet eine Suchaktion.
Mit dabei: Rettungschef Bruno Jelk.
Diese Stelle möchte ich anschauen.
Auf diesem Gletscher
unter dem Klein Matterhorn
ist vor einem Jahr
eine Japanerin verschollen.
Sie hatte das Skigebiet
leichtsinnig verlassen,
ist mit dem Snowboard
in eine Gletscherspalte gestürzt
und nicht mehr aufgetaucht.
Nun haben Rettungschef Bruno Jelk
und sein Team
vom japanischen Konsulat und
den Eltern den Auftrag bekommen,
ihre Leiche zu suchen.
Irgendwo hier unten, in der Weite
der Gletscherwelt, liegt sie,
in der Tiefe des Eises.
Auf der Basis
ist das deutsche Ehepaar Kaspar
auf der Spurensuche nach ihrem Sohn.
Karin Imboden
holt die Akten aus dem Archiv.
Das war ein Einsatz im Jahr 2004.
Weil ...
Das war ein Absturz am ...
... am Rotgrat, 2004.
Die Angehörigen dieses Gastes
sind jetzt hier.
Sie möchten mit jemandem reden,
der am Einsatz beteiligt war.
Wir sehen nach,
wer am Einsatz beteiligt war
und ob derjenige heute hier ist,
um mit den Eltern zu sprechen.
Sie haben nach zwei Jahren
den Mut gefunden, hierherzukommen,
um das Ereignis aufzuarbeiten.
Pilot Robi Andenmatten musste damals
den Sohn nach dem Absturz bergen.
Seit zwei Jahren
quälen sich die Eltern mit Fragen,
zu denen sie
keine Antworten fanden.
Nun haben sie allen Mut
zusammengenommen und hoffen,
den Tod ihres Sohnes
besser verstehen zu können.
Er ist der Pilot,
der den Einsatz geflogen ist.
Er ist auch Bergführer.
Sie können mit ihm reden.
Bruno Jelk und sein Bergführerteam
machen sich bereit
für eine aufwendige Suchaktion
nach der Japanerin.
Am Rand einer Spalte
stellen sie das Dreibein auf,
an dem sich die Bergretter
in die Gletscherspalte abseilen -
in der Hoffnung,
am richtigen Ort zu suchen.
Wir müssen daran glauben,
sie zu finden.
Wir hoffen, dass wir sie finden.
Aber es ist so, dass sich
die Gletscher verschieben
und die Spalten zusammenstürzen.
Deshalb ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
sehr klein.
Aber wir hoffen trotzdem,
sie zu finden.
Ein Bergführer seilt sich
ins Innere des Gletschers ab.
Sanfte Musik
Gut. Ich brauche viel Seil.
Okay. Stopp!
Mehr Seil, bitte!
Stopp!
Beim Suchen macht man Schwing-
bewegungen in Form einer Acht.
Mit einem Spezialgerät sucht er
die Spalte Meter um Meter ab.
Wenn es eine Schneebrücke hat,
kann man auch tief fallen.
Sphärische Musik
Jawohl.
Richi, auf!
Gut. Danke!
Nichts gefunden?
Nein, da ist nichts.
Es ist ein Riesenloch.
Ich war bis ganz dort unten.
Und hier auch.
Das ist ein riesiger Hohlraum.
Hier ist es gut,
aber dort müssen wir aufpassen.
Auf der Basis können die Kaspars
endlich Fragen stellen.
Wir wollten noch einmal an den Ort,
wo das geschehen ist.
Unser Sohn liebte die Berge
unheimlich.
Er war zehnmal auf dem Matterhorn.
Er bestieg alle 4'000-er
dieser Region.
Wie mein Mann schon sagte,
wollte er auf das Weisshorn.
Doch dann hat er umgebucht,
weil das Wetter schlecht war.
Ja.
Und dann löste sich
auf 3'900 m diese Felswand.
Genau.
Die haben nichts mehr gemerkt,
nicht?
Sobald sie gefallen sind ...
- Nein, nein. Das ist so.
Das geht alles so schnell und ...
Er sucht nach Worten.
Wenn man denkt, ist es schon vorbei.
Ja, ganz klar. Es geht so schnell,
da bekommt man nichts mehr mit.
Meistens ist der erste Aufschlag ...
- ... tödlich.
Er ist der Weg ins andere Leben.
Das ist so.
Im Endeffekt ...
Es ist halt das Leben,
und es sind halt die Berge.
Auf dem Gletscher geht die Suche
nach der Leiche der Japanerin weiter.
Die Angehörigen möchten natürlich,
dass wir die Leiche, die Person,
finden.
Darum geht es.
Für die Angehörigen
ist es schwierig zu verstehen,
wenn es keine Leiche gibt.
Da haben sie einfach Mühe.
Wir haben hier in Zermatt
über 20 Vermisste.
Die Angehörigen
melden sich immer wieder.
Sie können einfach
nicht verkraften ...
Rauschendes Funkgerät
unterbricht den Satz.
... dass man sie nicht findet.
Sie können oft nicht begreifen,
dass man die Person nicht findet.
Man muss die Leute verstehen
und sich in ihre Lage versetzen.
Dir fehlt ein Kind.
Da schöpft man alle möglichen Mittel
aus, um es zu finden.
Ein Wahrsager hat sich gemeldet.
Sie soll dort drüben sein.
In der Mulde?
Dort drüben, in diesen Spalten.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Das ist doch Humbug.
Die Aktion ist auch für die Rettungs-
spezialisten nicht ungefährlich.
Das Eis in den Gletscherspalten
ist brüchig,
und die dünne Schneedecke,
auf der sie sich bewegen,
kann jeden Moment einbrechen.
Sphärische Klänge
Hier geht es noch
ein paar Meter tiefer.
Unheimliche Musik
Unterdessen auf der Basis.
Wir sind jetzt hier
und ich möchte es ganz gerne.
Er wollte immer, dass mein Mann
auch einen Rundflug macht. Aber ...
Ich fühle mich dem
psychisch nicht gewachsen.
Zudem habe ich
Thrombosen in den Beinen.
Da ist der Höhenunterschied
vielleicht nicht gut.
Ich möchte es ganz gerne.
Die Berge sind wunderschön.
Wunderschön.
Eines muss ich Ihnen noch sagen:
Wir sind dankbar, dass wir ihn
so lange haben durften.
Wir hatten einen tollen Sohn
und tolle Erinnerungen.
Super, das ist die Hauptsache.
Das muss ich Ihnen auch noch sagen:
Alles war irgendwie ...
Der Rucksack ...
Alles war zerstört.
Selbst die Geldscheine im Geldsack
waren zerrissen.
Wir fanden einen Zettel,
der unversehrt war.
Ein Gedicht von Rainer Maria Rilke,
"Erinnerungen".
Am Ende steht: "Das war's".
- "Das war's."
Das ist Fügung.
Da können wir nichts machen.
Morgen sieht die Welt vielleicht
schon wieder etwas anders aus.
Richtig. Wir möchten uns
ganz herzlich bedanken.
Vielen Dank. Kommen Sie vorbei,
wenn Sie sich entschieden haben!
Hallo, Dani, war's gut?
Die Kaspars
müssen sich nun entscheiden,
ob sie den Flug zur Absturzstelle
gemeinsam machen werden.
Am Matterhorn sind die Verhältnisse
nach wie vor schlecht und gefährlich.
Nur wenige Bergsteiger
sind unterwegs.
Einzig die Rumänen
haben ihren Plan durchgezogen,
befinden sich nun aber im Abstieg.
Nach zwei Tagen sind sie
wieder zurück bei ihrem Zelt.
Bei guten Verhältnissen dauert die
Matterhorn-Besteigung rund 9 Std.
Else will wissen, wie es ihnen geht.
Ich sage nichts.
Wart ihr auf dem Gipfel?
Yes? This morning?
Ja, aber kein Kommentar.
Ihr wart auf dem Gipfel?
Natürlich.
Wie lange habt ihr gebraucht?
Ich sagte, kein Kommentar.
Ich will keine Fragen beantworten.
Wie war es?
Waren viele Leute unterwegs?
Nein, nein. Natürlich nicht.
Nun, dann wünsch ich euch
alles Gute!
Good way down!
Okay, bye bye.
Auf der Terrasse der Hörnlihütte
informiert sie Kurt Lauber
über ihr seltsames Gespräch.
Um 13.30 Uhr
sind sie beim Camp eingetroffen.
Als erstes sagte er,
es hätte zu wenig Schnee gehabt,
um nicht auf den Gipfel
gehen zu können.
Das ist ein typisches Beispiel,
wie man es nicht machen sollte.
Hätte das Wetter geändert,
hätten wir sie holen können.
Wer Hilfe für einen Platz
in der Solvay gebraucht hätte,
hätte keinen Platz mehr gehabt.
Zum Glück ist die Geschichte
positiv ausgegangen.
Ja.
Gegen Abend ziehen Wolken auf.
Für die nächsten Tage
ist schlechtes Wetter angesagt.
Das verheisst nichts Gutes.
Denn viele Bergsteiger
sind noch unterwegs,
und die Bergretter
können nicht fliegen.
Auf der Basis ist ein Notruf
eines jungen Paars eingegangen,
das letzte Nacht am Zinalrothorn vom
schlechten Wetter überrascht wurde.
Philipp berät sich mit Gerold.
Was läuft jetzt genau
mit den beiden?
Kurt sagte, er wolle weitersehen,
wenn das Wetter besser wird.
Sieht er von der Hörnlihütte etwas?
Es soll besser sein.
Wenn er denkt, das man fliegen
kann, bietet er uns sofort auf.
Dann holen wir ihn
und fliegen weiter.
Eine weitere Nacht könnte
für die beiden kritisch werden.
Ja ...
- Sonst gibt es eine Fussrettung.
Das müsste man sich jetzt überlegen.
Bis die dort oben sind,
kann es 3, 4 Std. dauern.
Wir müssen zwischen
13 und 13.30 Uhr entscheiden wir.
Tüftler Patrese nutzt das schlechte
Wetter auf seine Art und Weise.
Bereits seit ein paar Tagen
schweisst und bastelt er
auf der Basis im Geheimen
an einer speziellen Treppe
für Heli-Passagiere.
Ich denke
an ältere und behinderte Menschen.
Diese Treppe soll ihnen helfen,
besser einsteigen zu können.
Ich muss sie patentieren lassen,
dann ist alles gut.
Ich bastle gerne.
Die Situation des jungen Paares
am Zinalrothorn hat sich zugespitzt.
Eine weitere Nacht in der Kälte
würde für sie kritisch.
Trotz Nebel, Wolken und Wind
wagt Robi mit Flughelfer Reto
und zwei Bergführern
einen Rettungsversuch.
Rotorenlärm übertönt das Gespräch.
Spannende Musik, Helikopterlärm
Oben am Zinalrothorn
hat sich der Nebel wieder verdichtet.
Robi setzt die beiden Bergführer
in der Nähe des erschöpften Paares
auf einer Flanke ab.
Die Bergführer funken mit Robi.
Funk:Robi, antworten.
-Ja, Kurt?
Funk:Robi, was ist dir lieber?
Mit der Winde oder schwebend?
Funk:Lieber mit der Winde.
Ich fahre sie 3 m raus.
Funk:Gut. Dann kannst du weg.
Funk:
Jawohl. Bist du bereit?
Die Kletterer sollen
mit der Seilwinde aufgenommen werden.
Funk:
Der Wind kommt von Westen.
Schau mal hier! Schau, Paul, schau!
Doch die Windböen werden
immer stärker und unberechenbarer.
Funk:Es windet heftig,
ich muss einen Moment warten.
Funk:Robi, wenn es dir
lieber ist, machen wir es anders.
Funk:Meine Güte, dieser Wind!
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Funk:Ich kann ihn kaum halten.
Es ist zu gefährlich.
Pilot Robi
bricht die Aktion fürs Erste ab.
Auf der Basis
testet Patrese sein Gestell.
Ich muss dieses Blech
herausnehmen.
Einkaufswagen. Flott.
Und abstellen.
Drehen und rauf!
Am Zinalrothorn wagt es Robi erneut.
Funk:Okay.
Du kannst mir die 2 geben.
Er will die Kletterer dieses Mal
nicht mehr mit der Seilwinde,
sondern schwebend einladen.
Spannende Musik, Helikopterlärm
So ist es gut.
Zuerst auf die Kufe.
Über die Kufe
und dann langsam hinein.
Funksprüche
werden vom Roterenlärm übertönt.
Funk:Dann kannst du
gleich Felix mitnehmen.
Nun fliegt er das Paar zu einem
Zwischenlandeplatz weiter unten.
Funk:Wir fliegen gleich
hinunter zum Trift.
Ist gut.
Schau, wie es beschlägt.
Doch kurz vor der Landung im Tal
beschlagen sich die Scheiben
des Helikopters - Blindflug.
Die Kletterer
sind sich anscheinend nicht bewusst,
welche Risiken die Retter
auf sich genommen haben,
um sie aus der Notsituationen
zu evakuieren.
Bist du verletzt?
- Nein.
Was ist denn passiert?
Wir gerieten gestern
in einen furchtbaren Sturm.
Als wir oben waren, hat es
nur noch gehagelt und geregnet.
Da war dann nur noch ...
Da waren Wasser und Eis am Werk.
- Ja.
Wir fanden den Weg nicht.
Wenn man nicht weiss, wo man durch
muss, findet man den Abstieg nicht.
Seid ihr von Montet her gekommen?
- Genau.
Wir sind über den Nordgrat gekommen.
Dann wollten wir ...
Wichtig ist, dass alles okay ist.
- Ja.
Auf der Basis sichern derweil die
Air-Zermatt-Mitarbeitr ihre Helis.
Wir müssen die Rotorblätter halten,
weil ein Heli im Anflug ist.
Es könnte etwas wackeln.
Sie erwarten keinen Sturm,
sondern den Anflug des italienisches
Rettungshelikopters Agusta Bell 139.
Er ist grösser, kräftiger,
leistungsfähiger
und etwa gleich teuer wie
die gesamte Flotte der Air Zermatt.
Bestückt ist er mit einer Armada
von Ärzten, Rettungssanitätern
und Flughelfern,
welche eine Italienerin,
die sich im Skigebiet von Zermatt
verletzt hat,
in ein italienisches Spital
zurückfliegen sollen.
Markus interessiert sich aber
v.a. für den Helikopter.
Ich rufe dich an,
wenn ich mehr weiss.
Robi ist wieder zurück auf der Basis.
Sind alle Helis wieder zurück?
War es heavy, oben am Grat?
Zögernd:Ja.
Es ist ...
Man muss immer auch
auf den andern Heli schauen.
Reto sagte, er hätte nie
die Distanz abschätzen können.
Er musste sich stets abwenden,
damit ich etwas sehe.
Du musst immer
gleich viel Risiko eingehen.
Nicht wahr, Robi?
Was geht, geht.
Es muss funktionieren. Du musst
einen sichern Weg gehen können,
egal, ob jemand schwer verletzt ist
oder ob ihm nichts fehlt.
Man regt sich danach auch weniger
über Dilettanten auf.
Es ist besser,
man holt sie runter,
sonst kann man sie morgen
vom Fels kratzen.
Dieser Heli ist ein absoluter Traum!
Er ist wirklich
das Neuste vom Neuen,
sowohl bezüglich Elektronik
als auch Leistung.
Er ist einfach ...
Aber man muss realistisch bleiben:
Für eine Gebirgsbasis wie unsere
ist er zu gross.
Seine Grösse
hat natürlich auch Nachteile.
Aber als SAR oder Rettungsheli ist
er etwas vom Besten, das es gibt.
Ciao!
So ...
Feierabend für Gerold.
Salut!
Chauffeur de camion.
Das kann ich schon machen.
Ich schaue nach,
macht ihr in Ruhe fertig.
Rotorenlärm
Schau mal, wie der powert!
Sinnlose power.
Unglaublich!
Man will immer das,
was man nicht hat.
Bruno Jelk ist auf dem Weg zum Hotel
des deutschen Ehepaars Kaspar,
das seinen Sohn vor zwei Jahren
auf tragische Weise
bei einem Absturz verloren hat.
Jelk war damals bei der Bergung
auch dabei.
Nachdem sie bereits
mit Robi gesprochen haben,
erhoffen sich die Kaspars auch von
ihm Antworten auf Fragen zu bekommen,
die sie seit zwei Jahren quälen.
Guten Abend, Herr Jelk!
Sie sind Herr Jelk?
- Ja. Guten Abend.
Das ist Schicksal.
Sie sind der Leiter der ...
... der Rettungsstation Zermatt, ja.
Es wäre schön, wenn Sie uns
noch irgendetwas erzählen könnten.
Das war so ein Pech-Unfall,
wie er auch beim Autofahren
passieren kann.
Ich habe gelesen, dass es
eine sekundäre Ursache gab.
Das heisst, es war kein eigenes
Fehlverhalten oder Nichtkönnen,
sondern der Stein,
der sich gelöst hat.
Der Stein hat sich gelöst.
Schon vor 50 Jahren
haben die alten Bergführer
diesen Stein
immer zum Sichern benützt.
Mehr können wir nicht mehr tun.
Wir hätten auch lieber
etwas mehr oder anders gemacht.
Aber manchmal
sind wir halt machtlos.
Ich möchte ganz gerne,
mein Mann vielleicht nicht,
am Donnerstag kommen
und einen Heliflug machen.
Es sollte schon persönlich sein.
Ich möchte es ganz gerne.
Ich möchte einmal sehen ...
Und zwar ...
Weil er die Berge ...
Nicht, wo er abge...
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das sagen soll.
Ich möchte sehen,
warum er die Berge so geliebt hat
und was ihn so fasziniert hat.
Um welche Zeit
möchten Sie am Donnerstag fliegen?
Wann haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, gut ...
Bei mir ist das immer ungewiss.
11 Uhr?
- Das Wetter muss auch stimmen.
Ich würde am Morgen fliegen,
dann ist die Sicht besser.
Man kann nicht mehr tun,
als ihre Fragen zu beantworten.
Ich denke, sie verkraftet es besser,
er hat mehr Mühe damit.
Er hat sehr viel Mühe damit.
Ich denke,
dass er immer Mühe damit haben wird.
Er verkraftet das nicht so schnell.
Der Unfall geschah vor zwei Jahren.
Er reagiert auch nach zwei Jahren
noch immer sehr emotional.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass er es verkraftet.
Die Frau eher.
Mal schauen, wie es am Donnerstag
läuft, wenn wir fliegen.
Aber was soll ich sagen?
Ich kann nichts anderes sagen.
Es ist immer schwierig,
Angehörige eines Opfers zu treffen.
Aber das gehört auch dazu.
Notruf am Matterhorn.
Die Bergretter
waren bereits auf dem Weg nach Hause,
als die Meldung von der Hörnlihütte
eingegangen ist.
Pilot Markus und die Bergretter
machen auf dem Heliport
die "Lama" bereit.
Absturz am Matterhorn.
Das kann alles bedeuten.
Totalabsturz oder verletzt ...
Wir holen Bruno ab und schauen dann,
wie es aussieht.
Spannende Musik
Was erwartet sie am Matterhorn?
Gemeinsam mit Arzt Oli
und dem Flughelfer Furri
holt Markus Bruno Jelk zu Hause ab.
Funk:
Alles gut, du kannst los.
Funk:Wir sind vor 5 Minuten
Richtung Hörnligrat gestartet.
Funk:Verstanden. Vor 5 Minuten
Funk:Zur Information:
weibliche Patientin, 20 Jahre alt,
trägt gelbe Jacke.
Funk:
Das ist verstanden.
Okay. Oli, hast du alles dabei?
Ja.
Funk:Wie es aussieht,
könnte es eine Patientin sein.
Funk:
Heli Alpha 14.
Funk:Kurt,
wir sind unterwegs zur Ostwand.
Funk:Gut, ich habe sie gesehen.
Dann funken sie mit Kurt Lauber
in der Hörnlihütte.
Eine Bergsteigerin
ist in die Ostwand abgestürzt.
Funk:
Schau zuerst unten nach.
Von hier aus sehe ich nicht alles.
Pilot Markus steuert den Heli
zuerst zur Unfallstelle in der Wand
um herauszufinden, was passiert ist.
Funk:
Dort, geradeaus ist jemand.
Da, ich sehe sie! Dort unten.
Sie liegt im Couloir.
Ich fliege gleich runter.
Die verunfallte Bergsteigerin
liegt in einem Couloir.
Sie ist 200 m in die Tiefe gestürzt.
Funk:Da drüben.
Da ist nichts mehr zu machen.
Jede Hilfe kommt zu spät.
Funk:Kurt,
ich fliege Bruno und Oli rüber.
Funk:Ich nehme dich mit,
um die anderen vom Grat zu holen.
Funk:
Das ist gut, Markus.
Von der Hörnlihütte aus
bei Kurt Lauber
soll die Bergung
koordiniert und vorbereitet werden.
Unten auf der Basis
sind die Mechaniker an der Arbeit.
Sie führen Servicearbeiten
an einem der fünf Helikopter durch.
Peinlich genau
prüft Mechaniker Ernesto
die Rotorblätter auf allfällige Risse
und Loslösungen.
Die kleinste Unachtsamkeit
kann grosse Folgen haben.
Wenn es Loslösungen hat,
klingt es ganz anders.
Dann tönt es stumpf.
Jetzt tönt es klar.
Bruno Jelk
bereitet sich bei der Hörnlihütte
auf die Leichenbergung
am Matterhorn vor.
Funk:
Ich bin bereit.
Gemeinsam mit dem Arzt
wird er unter dem Heli am Seil
zur abgestürzten Bergsteigerin
in die Wand geflogen.
Jeder muss dem anderen bedingungslos
vertrauen können.
Funk:Furri, ist alles gut?
- Jawohl.
Funk:
Furri, ich wäre einfach froh,
wenn du oben auf Steine und
die Rotorfreiheit schauen könntest.
Das ist im Moment das Wichtigste.
Auf die Rotorblätter
und die Umgebung.
Ja, da wäre ich sehr froh.
Funk:Vorne sind es 4 m.
Oben ist es gut.
Markus setzt Bruno Jelk und den Arzt
am Unfallort ab.
Funk:Bruno, brauchst du
noch etwas zum Sichern?
Funk ist nicht zu verstehen.
Funk:
Brauchst du Kurt zum Sichern?
Warte einen Moment!
Die Unfallstelle ist eisig und steil.
Bruno Jelk
muss sich vorsichtig bewegen.
Er fotografiert
den Ort des Absturzes.
Bei der Hörnlihütte
wartet Kurt Lauber.
Er soll die überlebenden Kollegen
der abgestürzten Bergsteigerin
aus der Wand holen.
Sie waren es, die nach dem Absturz
um Hilfe gerufen haben.
Auf einer kleinen Alp
oberhalb von Zermatt
spürt Pilot Gerold nichts
von der Dramatik am Matterhorn.
Er hat heute seinen freien Tag,
den er mit seiner Frau Sabine
geniesst.
Sie sind zur Hütte aufgestiegen,
die schon seit Generationen
Gerolds Familie gehört.
Von hier aus beobachten sie
die Tiere am Waldrand.
Oberhalb der Scheune
kann man etwas sehen.
Fühlst du dich wohl hier?
- Wunderbar!
Das ist unser Paradies.
Um zu entspannen
gibt es keinen schöneren Ort.
Wir sehen gleich auf den Heliport.
Einen Wecker
brauchen wir auch nicht.
Hier, in der Abgeschiedenheit, findet
Gerold die Ruhe und den Ausgleich
zu seinem teilweise doch sehr
belastenden Job als Bergretter.
Ciao, zusammen!
Aus der Ferne:
Bei der Hörnlihütte steht Kurt Lauber
für seinen Einsatz bereit.
Er informiert sich bei Markus
über die Situation am Berg.
Funk:Nicht gut?
- Es sieht nicht gut aus.
Funk:
Da unten kann es nicht gut sein.
Funk:Sie liegt am tiefsten Punkt
des Couloir.
Funk:
Es hat gleich wieder einen Absatz.
Funk:Die dort oben dürfen
keine Steine ins Rollen bringen.
Kurt macht sich Sorgen,
dass sich bei der Rettung
der anderen Bergsteiger
durch den Wind der Rotorblätter
Steine aus der Wand lösen könnten,
die Bruno Jelk im Couloir gefährden.
Funk:
Kurt, ich hole zuerst Bruno raus.
Nicht dass noch etwas passiert.
Oder was meinst du?
Funk:
Das sollte kein Problem sein.
Die Bergsteigerkollegen
der jungen Frau
stehen direkt
oberhalb der Absturzstelle.
Helikopterlärm, spannende Musik
Sie beschliessen,
das Risiko einzugehen
und Kurt zu den
blockierten Bergsteigern zu fliegen.
Spannende Musik, Helikopterlärm
Auch Pilot Gerold hat schon viele
gefährlichen Einsätze geflogen.
Wie geht Ehefrau Sabine damit um?
Eigentlich habe ich keine Angst
mehr, wenn er weg ist.
Am Anfang
hatte ich viel mehr Angst.
Aber jetzt ... Nein.
Man gewöhnt sich daran.
Genau, man gewöhnt sich daran.
Manchmal ist die Angst schon da.
Wann hast du Angst? Nachts?
Bei schlechtem Wetter
oder wenn ich
kein gutes Gefühl habe.
Bisher hat sich das ungute Gefühl
zum Glück nie bewahrheitet.
Das Einzige,
das man dagegen tun kann ...
Man verabschiedet sich
am Morgen anders.
Das macht man sicher bewusster
als früher.
Es ist wichtig, nicht im Streit
aus dem Haus zu gehen.
Darauf achtet man schon.
Aber sonst kann man nicht viel tun.
Anweisungen via Funk
zum jeweiligen Standort des Helis.
Funk:
Vor 5, ab 2.
Vor 2.
Markus setzt Kurt
auf der schmalen Kante
bei den überlebenden Bergsteigern ab.
Funk:
Achtung, Bruno! Ein Rucksack kommt.
Plötzlich wird ein Rucksack
vom Abwind der Rotoren weggeblasen,
er fliegt genau in die Richtung
von Bruno Jelk und dem Arzt.
Funk:Es war ein Rucksack.
- Er ist vorbeigeflogen.
Doch es ist nichts passiert.
Sprecht ihr Englisch?
Wir werden euch jetzt
zur Hörnlihütte fliegen, alle drei.
Da unten steht noch einer,
ein Freund von uns.
Der Blaue dort unten.
Funk:Bruno, wie viele seid ihr?
-Drei. Du kannst kommen.
Markus hat nun die Aufgabe,
Bruno Jelk, den Arzt und die
abgestürzte Bergsteigerin zu bergen.
Funk:Vorne und am Heck
ist alles klar.
Spannende Musik
Funk:Alles gut, Bruno?
- Alles ist gut.
Spannende Musik
Funk:
Kurt, hast du schon alle ausgeladen?
Nein, Bruno, noch keinen.
Ich warte, bis ihr unten seid.
Ich muss zu Fuss
noch einen vierten Mann holen.
Kurt Lauber
instruiert die Überlebenden Freunde
über die bevorstehende Evakuierung.
Ohne Karabiner.
Es sind schon welche dran.
Bruno Jelks Arbeit ist getan.
Es ist schwer zu sagen.
Wir bekamen die Meldung: Absturz.
Sie war sehr gut ausgerüstet.
Vielleicht machte sie
mit den Steigeisen einen Fehltritt
oder etwas ist abgebrochen.
Ich gehe mir die Hände waschen.
Markus ist im Anflug zu Kurt Lauber
und den anderen Bergsteigern,
um sie herauszuholen.
Funk:
Noch 2 Meter.
Auf einen.
Funk:
Auf einen halben. Gut.
Kurt Lauber weist Pilot Markus ein.
Funk:
Auf 2 Meter.
Auf einen.
Funk:
Auf einen halben. Gut.
Funk:Gut, Markus,
du kannst anziehen.
Am Zwischenlandeplatz
gibt Bruno Jelk neue Anweisungen.
Wir packen hier zusammen
und fliegen dann zur Basis.
Ich muss noch eine Runde drehen,
um Fotos aus der Distanz zu machen.
Auf der Basis werde ich
die Fotos der Polizei zeigen.
Sie werden dann sagen,
ob das für sie reicht.
Alarmiert von den Bergrettern
trifft auf der Basis
der Kantonspolizist ein.
Per Funk erhält er Informationen
von Kurt Lauber,
der mit den Überlebenden
zurück in der Hörnlihütte ist.
Hier ist Pädi. Kannst du mir bitte
weitere Informationen liefern?
Wie viele sind es?
Insgesamt vier.
Mit der toten Person?
Eine Fünfer-Seilschaft.
Sie kommen mit der
verunglückten Frau auf die Basis.
Die Kollegen der Frau haben hier
die Zelte aufgeschlagen.
Willst du hinauf kommen,
um sie zu vernehmen
oder soll ich sie morgen
auf den Polizeiposten schicken?
Das ist gut.
Ich schaue,
dass der Bestatter informiert ist.
Gut. Danke, Patrick. Ciao.
Vielen Dank. Ciao.
Helikopterlärm
Vor knapp einer Stunde
befand sich die junge Bergsteigerin
noch im Abstieg zur Hörnlihütte.
Dann passierte der fatale Sturz
in die Tiefe.
So schmal und unbegreiflich
kann die Grenze zwischen Leben
und Tod am Matterhorn sein.
In der Hörnlihütte realisieren die
Freunde langsam, was passiert ist.
Sie stehen unter Schock
und wissen nicht weiter.
Rettungssanitäter Furri versucht
sie zu beruhigen und zu helfen.
Was sollen wir jetzt machen?
Wir waren noch nie
in einer solchen Situation.
Was sollen wir nun tun?
Kein Problem.
Wir gehen jetzt alle nach Zermatt.
Sie reden Englisch.
Wir gehen jetzt alle nach Zermatt?
Ja, ein Care-Team wird euch dort
betreuen und weiterhelfen. Okay?
Das Matterhorn
hat ein weiteres Opfer gefordert.
Pro Jahr sind es rund acht.
Oft sind es wie in diesem Fall
Unerfahrenheit
und schlechte Verhältnisse,
die zum Absturz führen.
Wie sich inzwischen
herausgestellt hat,
handelt es sich
um eine 23-jährige Polin
mit wenig Klettererfahrung.
Der Unfall
wird nun amtlich untersucht.
Das ist klar.
Es ist gut.
Bruno hat schon Fotos gemacht.
Falls es noch einen Flug gibt,
kann man noch einige mehr machen.
Sonst lassen wir es.
Drei sind noch hier.
Jelk
hat die Absturzstelle in der Ostwand
für die polizeilichen Untersuchungen
fotografiert.
Ich schaue es an und
nehme Rücksprache mit dem Richter.
Meiner Meinung nach
sind die Fotos gut zu gebrauchen.
Das ist von unten her fotografiert.
Hast du eine Übersichtsfoto?
- Ja.
Das ist hier.
Sie stürzte in dieses Couloir.
Das sollte reichen.
Ich frage den Richter,
ob er weitere Fotos will.
Pilot Markus
wurde vom Einsatz überrascht.
Er hatte seinen Dienst
eigentlich schon beendet.
Ich dachte, der Tag sei gelaufen.
Manchmal geht es eben schnell.
Aber ich war noch im Dorf
und hatte es nicht weit.
Damit muss man einfach rechnen.
Aufgrund der Wetter- und Schneelage
denkt man,
es seien wenige Leute unterwegs.
Aber genau in diesen Situationen
passiert es natürlich.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Kannst du abschalten?
Ja, das kann ich relativ gut.
Es wäre sicher anders,
wenn man die Leute gut kennen würde.
Aber so ist es einfach ...
Es ist sicher keine gewöhnliche
Arbeit, aber einfach ein Einsatz.
Für die Betroffenen hat dieser Tag
leider nicht so gut geendet.
Für uns ist es ein normaler Tag,
eine Rettung oder eben eine Bergung.
Man muss das so sehen.
Ja. Es wäre nicht gut, wenn man
eine Woche darüber nachdenken würde.
Dann wäre es schwierig.
Auf der Basis sind anderntags
die Eltern Kaspar eingetroffen.
Es ist der Todestag ihres Sohnes.
Gemeinsam mit Bruno Jelk
und Robi Andenmatten
wollen sie nun doch zur Absturzstelle
fliegen und Abschied nehmen.
Mit dem Flug hoffen sie,
endlich Ruhe zu finden.
Alles klar.
Wo kommt das rein?
Funk:Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Gut.
Funk:Alles klar.
In 5 Min. sind wir dort.
Funk:
Dort oben ist die Täschhütte.
Dort oberhalb des Weges
ist die Hütte.
Ein Jahr zuvor war ich mit ihm dort.
Bei der Täschhütte?
- Ja.
Sie sind von der Täschhütte
aufgebrochen.
Ja, dann sind sie
quer über diesen Grat.
Funk:
Mein Gott!
Sie sucht nach Worten.
Quer über den Grat, über die Felsen.
Funk:
Dann stiegen sie dort hinauf.
Sie stiegen dort hinauf
und kamen auf diese Kante
und dann dort hinunter.
Funk:
Ach, nein!
Das ist die Route.
Sie führt über den Grat.
Vorher gingen sie über das Couloir.
Meistens geht man über den Grat.
Funk:Und schon
wären sie oben gewesen.
Das hat er nicht mehr sehen können.
Funk:Ach, nein!
- Das ist der Gipfel.
Funk:Warum haben sie ihn
nicht erreicht?
Das darf man nicht fragen.
Die Frage nach dem Warum
nützt nicht viel.
Nein, nein.
Funk:
Das hat ihn so fasziniert.
Funk:So viele Steine.
Warum bricht ausgerechnet dann
ein Stein raus?
Das ist genau die Frage.
Sie sind dann
in diese Mulde abgestürzt.
Mit zittriger Stimme:
Hallo, Christoph! Wo bist du?
Funk:
Er ist hier.
Mit zittriger Stimme:
Vielen Dank!
Auf der Basis rauscht es,
wie die Crews der Air Zermatt sagen.
Für dich gibt es
noch einen Rundflug.
Robi kann die drei Personen
vom Monte Rosa holen.
Jungpilot Dani soll
einen Rundflug für Touristen machen.
Du musst mit Robi besprechen,
wer zum Monte Rosa fliegt.
Ich gehe mit Charlie Charlie.
Es geht darum, drei Personen
vom Monte-Rosa-Gletscher zu holen.
Das macht Robi?
- Ja.
Wenn er schon da ist.
Dann machst du den Rundflug.
Ist er gleich?
In ca. 10 Min. geht's los.
Du kannst dich bereit machen.
Okay.
Die Kaspars sind zurück.
Einmal mehr hat ihnen der Heliflug
den tragischen Tod ihres Sohnes
vor Augen gebracht.
Doch vielleicht können sie jetzt
besser verstehen und abschliessen.
Melancholische Musik
Wir waren jetzt dort.
Er war bei uns.
Patrese verpasst heute seiner
mobilen Treppe für Heli-Passagiere
den letzten Schliff.
Ich musste einiges ändern,
aber das Resultat ist so,
wie ich es wollte.
So, wie ich nachts davon träumte.
Ferrari-Rot.
Wer sie testen soll, ist klar.
Gerold.
Er ist zwar nicht der Älteste,
aber ich nehme ihn
als Versuchskaninchen.
Pilot Dani
hebt mit seinen Gästen ab ...
Rhythmische Musik
... in Richtung Weisshorn,
Matterhorn und Monte Rosa.
Über 8'000 Gäste pro Jahr entführen
die Piloten der Air Zermatt so
in die Bergwelt rund um Zermatt.
Funk:Es geht Richtung Täsch,
Randa, Weisshorn
und dann direkt zum Matterhorn.
Dort herrscht heute viel Betrieb,
wir werden viele Bergsteiger sehen.
Stell dir vor,
du wärst ein alter Mann.
Jetzt hier rüber.
Nun kommt für Patrese, den stolzen
Erbauer der mobilen Helitreppe,
der Moment der Wahrheit:
Test mit Gerold.
Und dann kann ich dir helfen
einzusteigen.
Soll ich ehrlich sein?
Der erste Tritt ist zu hoch.
Dieser hier?
- Ja.
Wenn er hier unten wäre,
könnte man besser aufstehen.
Die Idee ist gut.
Diesen Tritt
braucht es vielleicht gar nicht.
Wir haben ja auch
kaum ältere Leute.
Ob Patreses Gestell, in das er
so viele Stunden investiert hat,
wohl je zum Einsatz kommt?
Funk:Der Hohlicht-Gletscher ist
für mich der schönste Gletscher.
Frau:Er ist wunderschön.
Funk:
Schauen Sie diese Eistürme an!
Dani fliegt unterdessen
seine Touristen
über die zerklüfteten Gletscher
und Bergmassive
der Walliser 4000-er hinweg -
direkt auf das Matterhorn zu.
Funk:
Und da ist das Matterhorn!
Frau:Schau, wie schön!
Die Frau jauchzt vor Freude.
Mann:Es ist mega!
Mann:Schau dort, Bergsteiger!
Frau:Ja, sie sind am Absteigen.
Und so geht die Geschichte
über den Sommeralltag der Bergretter
der Air Zermatt zu Ende.
Sie sind die Retter in der Not,
sie retten Leben -
es ist ihr Beruf -
und auch eine Berufung.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich:
A. Marti (2007), C. Burri (2020)